did you hear what uh pinterest just said
pinterest just said uh last week i think
pinterest will not take down content
spreading climate change misinformation
this is uh uh let me go to what story
what page is that on it's on page three
i'll read this to you and then i'll get
your commentary on everything we just
discussed right now
so uh uh pinterest will take down
content spreading the climate change
mister formation
uh uh the announcement shows pinterest
known for providing a space to share
ideas about clothing food and furniture
is also getting into uh sustainability
the company is launching a preemptive
striking against climate change
information becoming the first social
media network to prohibit
users from sharing inaccurate data about
climate change the site will now use a
combination of automation and human
review to find misinformation remove it
and replace it with accurate articles
about climate change yeah well my only
first comment is i can't believe they
weren't doing that already i just
thought i assumed they all were it's
just sad because
youtube just recently demonetized
any climate skeptics from even getting
anything not that that didn't affect me
but the same thing everyone cheering on
what they did for russia uh right after
the invasion into ukraine where
banking government corporations all got
together and immediately just went after
and essentially shut the same thing that
trudeau did to the uh
truckers in canada
be very afraid because they can use that
directly back on someone if you hold
anti-covet views if you hold
anti-climate views anti-you know viral
scare views
this is all part essentially
you know davos crowd klaus schwab
small narrow window to reset our world
disinformation control of it is probably
the one of the most important things a
lot of their training sessions for
covert they talked about shutting down
the internet to stop misinformation
so i'm sure pinterest probably has a
covet policy very similar and these are
just the first steps they're going to
keep going and any i almost said idiot
but any person out there who says it's a
private company they should be able to
do what they want nothing's private
anymore big tech censorship is
government censorship when the white
house gives issues lists of names for
big tech corporations to censor and then
they follow suit and do it this is no
longer private companies so that's where
i get i get really angry with a lot of
the people on the
libertarian conservative who just think
oh this is this is their this is their
choice they can do it i don't know the
way to fight it is i don't think elon
musk is buying twitter by the way
everything i'm seeing is i think he's
looking for an out he's saying it's full
of bots and he's the whole deal is on
hold i have a feeling he's gonna walk
from this i think he just probably
doesn't want the hassle and i think in
the long term interest just personally
him it would probably destroy tesla if
he did what he's talking about doing at
twitter they're the establishments pet
company they will destroy that company
no matter what he's done on climate no
matter how popular he's been they will
get him and they have the power to do
that even to the world's wealthiest man
they will dismantle him i i don't think
it's a good move if he doesn't if he
backs out of it well he's looking for a
way i know he is i know what he's doing
because the whole 120 million dollars
that you know they're they're trying to
say because you waited a few days you
save yourself this much money by doing
that and the
now uh they're trying to investigate him
so obviously the one thing that's
obvious forget about the fact that
whether he wants to buy it or not
no one on the left wants him to buy
nobody yeah no even yesterday did you
see what the twitter ceo of twitter
tweeted yesterday and how he almost
reacted to it so yesterday the ceo
twitter put out how to address the uh
fight off all the bots
[Music]
and he wrote out a series of tweets
uh and elon musk's
so he says let's talk about spam and
let's do with the benefit of data facts
and context okay and he explains it in
this 10-part tweet or 15-part tweet that
he puts
and then on the bottom
what is uh how does elon musk respond to
it with a go go up go up go to replies
now go all the way up and go to replies
write their second one that says replies
and zoom in a little bit because we
can't see anything zoom in a little bit
okay keep going keep going keep going
and yeah there you go move it this is
how he responds there not that one keep
going you have to see how what he
responds with what emoji there it is
right there okay so process
unfortunately we don't believe that
senator jones performs
so the the part about uh
the bots elon musk's response
with a
what emoji is that
emoji okay a poop emoji that's
essentially if he buys a company that's
a ceo but he responds with a poop emoji
i don't think it's a good move for musk
to back out i don't think it's a good
move for muslim background he must he i
just read a whole alex berenson did a
thing he alex berenson thinks the deal's
over it's not going to happen i don't
know
he was probably looking at a collapse of
his whole enterprise possibly i mean
there they would be ruthless in going
after him i mean he could lose they're
going to be released no matter what with
them well even now but less so now
because if he backs down i think i i i
it appears to me he's he's looking for
every out but i don't know if he'll get
an out we'll see because now i think
twitter's suing him for the original
deal it's it's getting uh messy but
i i hope twitter
actually forces him to buy it okay i
hope they do okay because
the calls i'm getting the calls i'm
getting is i'm getting calls and i'm
getting on you know morgan stanley's
leading this whole thing goldman and
symbol but it's really morgan stanley's
deal and they're he's looking for guys
to come in this is what up the calls
i've been on rounds of 100 million cash
because he wants to you know you know
leverage some of the folks to get in as
well but you don't get to say anything
but i hope the deal goes through i think
it's going to be a very
um he may if he buys twitter he may be
the most influential man in the world
because he's gonna use his voice
if he buys it if he doesn't buy it
uh and he's smart enough to know how to
get out of it if there's anybody smart
enough to get out of a deal it's
probably a guy named elon musk let me
ask you about you're saying he's
basically looking for an off-ramp to get
out of the deal that's what it seems
like yeah because he's talking about
these bots and this was now an issue
looks like the point of contention is is
the are these bots and these fake
accounts i've seen it i've seen is that
really what he's worried about or is
that is there a bigger problem i think
he's i think he's just i think he's i
think all his investors all his partners
everyone is telling them this is the end
of tesla and very well i mean i don't
put anything past them i mean in terms
of what i say them i mean the
establishment it'll be the end of tesla
y if it goes through i just think that
they're going to do everything they can
in terms of government contracts
regulations support it could affect his
space ender's risers because a lot of
his the whole world has been okay so
that will between government and private
that's exactly why
taking money from the government is the
is not a freaking good move because they
eventually yeah strong army like like
he's talking about did you get that
spacex would you take money
they'll eventually say if you do this
here's what we're gonna do because we
fed you this that's exactly why the
nationalized system doesn't work exactly
that's exactly why that doesn't work
punishes
individuality any dissent you have to
toe the party line on everything same
thing we saw
on every i mean everything from climate
covered
um i was selling health insurance
obamacare comes out and all these guys
in l.a were like oh my god i'm still
obamacare on the ford let me tell you i
just sold 100 policies japan we're
making money so much money man you got
to get in i'm like yeah bro there's one
person i don't compete with and that's
the government i'm out i left i'm like
i'm not touching health insurance at all
they forced everybody to use three or
five different insurance companies every
year i saw my premium going up for what
i had to pay for as an employer i'm like
yeah i'm not competing with you guys
you're right you win obama you win i'm
out we'll go to a different industry
that you're not going to be involved
what's the correlation there or the
lesson there with elon musk and what
he's doing with tesla and potentially
with twitter the correlation is
ah man let's look i i'm watching you
you're watching this amber hurt and uh
johnny depp what a sweetheart of a girl
she is right just listen to it the more
the more i watch her like they showed
her recording yesterday
of how she's like you know the attorney
says do you know why johnny doesn't look
at your eyes do you don't by the way you
have to use a restroom no no
do you know why johnny doesn't look at
your eyes
and he's like no do you look at johnny's
eyes in court i do does he look at you
no do you know why i don't know you
should know i don't know then she plays
the recording
and it's a recording of johnny and amber
and she's like please stop touching me
he's like come on please i just want it
one more time i want to hug you because
i i know i'm so ugly i was like stop
touching me it says
you will never
see these eyes look at you ever again
never you hear in the recording
johnny got to a point that i will never
can you imagine a loved one telling you
i will never make eye contact because
you know love the eye contact i will
never look at you ever again right
you've seen all these things being
revealed about where it's at and how
power structure and manipulation when
somebody gets a hold of you dude amber
heard is a small government controlling
a guy that she almost ruined his life
because he came out and said this guy
beat me you know what was a question
that the lawyer asked i love the
question says hey does johnny uh always
wear these rings as long as i know he
always has these rings on is it fair to
say these are not small rings no is it
fair to say he wears very big gory rings
you know not gory rings like just gotti
rings yeah yes has he always for as long
as i know he's always warned this he
says okay great this is the picture you
showed that he hits you
what would happen if he hit you with
these rings
you're like what a freaking great point
if he's hit you as many times as you
claim he's hit you how come you don't
have any scars for them from from these
rings this guy this girl ruined the
guy's life for what she did and he comes
out it's so weird can you imagine a man
saying yeah i'm suing my wife for
domestic violence yeah yeah that's your
emancipator right yeah anyways the
government yeah is doing to musk
what potentially amber heard did to
johnny and i hope
musk responds like johnny did i hope
musk responds like johnny did because
somebody has to stop the bullying and if
that is really what is going on behind
closed doors if there is a guy that can
do that it's this crazy guy it's him
yeah and uh that doesn't mean they're
not gonna stop coming after you that
doesn't mean they're not gonna stop uh
playing games with them that doesn't
mean they're not gonna stop trying to
get sec tax they're gonna find some [ __ ]
on this guy that if they want to do it
but the alternative is what you're
officially owned by the government you
officially have to get a tattoo that
says i'm government-owned property so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]